on l'état va donc donner un sérieux coup
de pouce à la géothermie et vu les prix
du fioul ces dernières années ce système
a déjà connu un essor incroyable avec
une augmentation des installations de 15
à 20% par an le procédé est simple il
s'agit de récupérer la chaleur de notre
bonne vieille planète terre
l'état subventionne déjà les
installations ce qui a décidé un certain
nombre de particuliers reportage en
bretagne éric pineault michel hiver un
forage selah sue la terre que les
systèmes de chauffage par géothermie
vont chercher les calories naturelle du
sol à 100 mètres de profondeur il fait
environ 14 degrés une température
constante toute l'année quelle que soit
la météo en surface dans ce trou en un
produit une sombre dont on voit
l'extrémité ici voilà ce qu'on appelle
la tête de sombres je fais descendre
cette cendre au fond du trou et dans 7
centres je fais circuler de l'eau et
c'est tôt en arrivant au fond du trou il
fait à peu près entre 12 et 14 degrés
bassetto se réchauffe et remonte chaude
à la surface ce qui permet de chauffer
ma maison simplement en récupérant ses
calories des calories qui sous-tend
suite optimisée par une pompe à chaleur
qui va augmenter la température pour
fonctionner la pompe a tout de même
besoin d'électricité mais quand elle
consomme 1 kilowatt l on restitue 400
garantie pour nos clients c'est de
pouvoir chauffer une maison qui fait 130
m² pour un budget annuel de 250 euros
par an sous les sabots de ce cheval 500
m² de tuyaux capte aussi les calories du
sol plus de forages cette fois mais un
système horizontale invisible et
efficace le propriétaire des lieux a
ainsi remplacé sa chaudière à fuel tout
en conservant ses radiateurs j'arrivais
à 2500 euros pratiquement de
consommation annuelle au fioul
aujourd'hui je suis à peu près à mi
lourds aux gets à 1000 euros si vous
voulez pour faire un chiffre rond
l'installation coûte en moyenne quinze
mille euros pour une maison de 130 m² un
crédit d'impôt permet d'alléger la
facture si vous payez d'installation
pour simplifier 10000 euros vous allez
avoir 4000 euros de déductions fiscales
ou de crédit d'impôt donc c'est quand
même considérable
ce dispositif fiscal durera au moins
jusqu'à la fin 2009 il s'applique aussi
aux
pompes à chaleur qui puisent les
calories dans l'eau ou plus simplement
dans l'air ambiant autres